distance D so that's what this is torn
up that's just the pruning rule they've
chosen to use travel by Craig a marathon
runner varies directly with time T so
there's the key phrase they laid out as
clearly as they possibly can it varies
directly that means more time equals
more distance travel fair enough
right a variation equation for D right a
variation equation for D so we want to
encapsulate this relationship in a nice
succinct way that includes time and
distance so when you have a look we want
an equation for D so how is it related
to time have a look at the numbers there
they have deliberately given you fairly
straightforward numbers distance can you
see it's always time multiplied by a
particular number you can use your
calculator to verify it if you like here
this is divided by x that's speed right
that would be 190 this is divided by
time for this 380 divided by 2 is still
190 it's the same for the last one right
so I would say that distance is always
the time multiplied by 180 does that
make sense and from there I can sort of
extrapolate what about after 4 minutes 5
minutes 50 minutes however long I want
he's a marathon runner which I guess is
what accounts for his incredibly
consistent speed because most of us do
not run like this but that's that's all
it is
that's the variation equation that goes
through this dialogue I'll say 190 yeah
of course
I just can't write numbers that's all
okay so make sense can you read B part
one for you what is it what does it ask
for what does B paulanos halt if I want
to know distance after 20 minutes 20
minutes is a time right so I'm just
going to write 20 times
it and Daiki right so you see just by
evaluating this I've got to get what
3800 degree with that now this is a
distance in have a look at the question
what units this is it meters right what
have they asked for the answer to be in
this question very carefully have a look
they're worried callers so I would
encourage you to write actually M for
meters there to indicate the unit and
then after that let's convert into
kilometers so what do i do determine
tickle is divided by thousands perfect
because there's a thousand meters in
every corner so I've got to get that
happy times okay let's do the very last
one you can do part two in your in time
because same idea they asked this time
for a time don't they a time for what
read the question what do they ask you
for time to do what what time for Craig
or whatever his name was to run half are
twelve point three five kilometers okay
so twelve point three five kilometers
that's the distance right so that's
going to be equal to some time times
keep writing the roll number one hundred
and ninety okay like so just like in the
previous question it's a good idea to do
that conversion is and say that you're
doing it so I've written kilometers how
many means is that how many meters I
converting in the opposite direction so
I'm not going to divide by a thousand
are going to multiply by thousands
which gives you that and this is an
equation that I've been dealing with for
ages right what am I going to do on both
sides divided by 190 could someone give
me the yourself does it give you
decimals yes go exactly 65 what unit of
claim is that what you know time is it
look at the question that's 65 hours
days years
it's minutes right what unit does the
question what our odds are in they want
hours and minutes so I would say
therefore the time is 1 hour 5 minutes
you're done